The train now approaching platform two is the 11:07 southern service to London Bridge.
This train is the service from Horsham.
Redhill, this is Redhill.
The train now standing at platform two is the 11:07 southern service to London Bridge.
Calling at Merstham, Coulsdon South, Purley,...
...East Croydon, Norwood Junction, New Cross Gate and London Bridge.
Southern are sorry to announce that the 1300 hours southern service...
...to Southampton Central and Bognor Regis is delayed by approximately 12 minutes...
...due to awaiting of a portion of the train.
Please listen for further announcements.
Southern are very sorry for the delay to this service.
The next service from this platform will be the 13:10 southern service to Horsham.